vingt mille étudiants répartis sur cinq
campus yvelinois lu vs qu propose plus
de 200 formations diplômantes du dut au
doctorat elle apparaît dans plusieurs
classements internationaux parmi les
plus prestigieux shanghai ou encore
celui du times higher education et saint
quentin en yvelines accueille également
sur son territoire de nombreux
établissements pour des formations plus
spécialisés la filière du transport est
représenté avec l'estac à l'école basée
à montigny le bretonneux propose des
formations d'ingénieurs en cinq ans
après le bac
l'automobile est depuis la rentrée 2010
8 son propre campus à guyancourt samson
jeunes se forment dans le commerce mais
aussi la maintenance auto moto et vélo
pour celles et ceux qui souhaitent opter
pour les métiers de bouche le lycée
d'hôtellerie et de tourisme est
implantée à guyancourt à plaisir l'école
lenôtre permet également de se former
aux métiers de cuisine ou de pâtissier
son spectacle images le premier campus
audiovisuel européen se trouve à saint
quentin en yvelines plus précisément à
elancourt avec plus de 12000 mètres
qu'arrive d'infrastructures 3e reçoit
près de 900 étudiants chaque année
enfin devenir développeur web community
manager ou analystes en cybersécurité en
quelques mois seulement
en 2018 l agglomération a lancé son
label école du numérique
cet organisme a labellisé propose une
quinzaine de formations
objectif répondre aux besoins des
entreprises saint-quentinoise